to say something for the people who are
online so if you're online and you have
a question to ask
for now we'll try to have you just
interrupt the just unmute yourself and
ask the question
if you have a question you want to dress
live
that's how we'll do it
[Music]
it even online if you don't hear me well
let me know i'll try to start talk
louder
so okay in this lecture um
which is uh we'll see how to draw those
pictures that we were drawing in the
last lecture um
so
and so i'm going to talk about belief
propagation
i should warn you that uh i'm very far
from being an expert on this topic so
maybe a good thing maybe a bad thing you
see
all right so
what is the goal of belief propagation
well you have uh
this distribution the posterior
distribution
uh just to remind you it's e to the
minus beta g of x where g of x is
this quadratic
and our goal
is
to
you know compute the
let's say the marginals
of each variable
um
i mean
so um
for each vertex i you want to know
what's the product x is one
so
i think as i've described it the problem
is little bit
annoyingly trivial because
of because of symmetry
the expected marginal of every variable
is
zero because if there's a some property
of being plus one there's an equal
product being minus one just because the
symmetry of the model
but that's not really interesting so
let's ignore that issue throughout the
talk let's assume that you have some of
uh conditioned on one of the signs or
something so
um
but really you have some
boltzmann distribution which looks like
e to the minus beta g of x
and you want to estimate the margins
okay
so
right so
um
okay so how do we estimate the marginals
well
let me
start writing something so
okay so let's
so
just to write down what the marginal is
so the probability
so the probability
that
let's say vertex u
is equal to some value sigma u
okay this is of course
equal to
sum over all x
with x u equal to sigma u
of e to the minus beta g of x
divided by z of g
okay
um
[Music]
sigma u is let's say plus one so the
probability that it's plus one is
exactly this okay um so the numerator is
something where
you're summing up these e to the beta g
of x only on
assignments x
where the vertex u is assigned sigma u
okay just think of sigma u is plus 1.
so the numerator will call it something
else
let's call it z of
g conditioned on
x u equal to one
okay so that's uh
that's what the numerator looks like
okay so that's good um
all right so now uh
so here's what we'll try we'll try
to do the following
you have a graph
your vertex u i'm going to draw the
vertex u outside
and then the vertex u has a neighborhood
it has a neighborhood
and let me call n of you are the
neighbors of vertex u
okay and you know we do the
natural
uh conditioning
idea here
so so you say okay well this is of
course
equal to sum
over
z
of g
oh sorry x equals sigma yeah thanks
okay so
so we'll say xu equal to sigma u
and
x
rest of the neighborhood of u is also
equal to some condition on the
neighborhood
okay so
divided by z of g
okay
so if i condition on the neighborhood
then
you know i can write
[Music]
the terms in this
sum
well sorry it's a sum overall x such
that the entire neighborhood of u is
assigned sigma n of u
okay
and x u is assigned sigma
so now uh if i condition on the entire
neighborhood then i can write then i can
take out the contribution of the
neighborhood to the hamiltonian to the g
of x
so i'm going to write
uh
[Music]
[Music]
because of this
conditioning of in the entire
neighborhood i can write this as
sum over all the assignments to the
neighbors
okay
all the two to the d assignments to the
neighbors
and then i can take out the contribution
to the neighbors because it's fixed now
because all of the terms in the
neighborhood are fixed
so for every
[Music]
so
every term in the neighborhood is fixed
because all the edges both end points
are fixed
and then you have the rest of the graph
so
let me call that g minus u right so let
me call that g
minus u
of x
okay so
essentially the hamiltonian or the g of
x splits into the edges that you see
here and the rest of the graph and you
can write it this way
sorry
that's the neighborhood
you have to remove the neighborhood
you take out all the edges going in
so you just move you and you keep the
neighbors just give you just
remove the edges going from you and so
you're left with the draw for the
remaining
okay and uh well what is this and i'm
going to start using proportionality
because i don't want to keep track of
normalization factors
so here
so here you are summing
you have like another sum over x is
something yes
sum over x and so yes
some more x and some other yeah and so
so then you know the
this is proportional to
well uh
and i'm just going to
um
so some of sigma and x okay so what what
i'll have is some i'll go back to sum of
sigma so that
we can see what's going on
sum over v in the neighborhood of u
sigma u sigma v
times
uh
z of
g minus u
condition of the neighborhood
yeah
it's
okay and and
well uh
all i want to say is that this quantity
is
is like the probability is proportional
to the probability
in g minus u
of uh
the sigma
the neighborhood being assigned sigma
okay
um
so
it's a
it's just a markov property of this
graphical model that once i condition on
the neighborhood
i know exactly what's the probability of
uh
the entire
space
um
knowing the probability on the left and
the property on the right and so that's
a
um
there are probably much more cleaner
ways to do this but but i probably
butchered this but but what i wanted to
get to was just this expression okay
this expression is something that's true
in every graph
okay it's just this idea that uh
um
the probability distribution on g
is
the product distribution on g minus u
you take the product distribution of g
minus u and you re-weigh
the distribution
by the hamiltonian of the neighborhood
just the e to the power minus
just the edges here okay it's a very
simple equality right
okay
yeah it is exactly that it's just micro
property yeah i mean i didn't have yeah
um
okay so
this is just true in every graph okay
just so far we're in good shape
okay so i'm going to copy that statement
here
okay
sorry
okay
i don't know why the animation here is
messed up i'm sorry about that ignore
this thing for now
pretend you don't see it for now okay so
so what what is uh
okay
what do we do now let's just imagine g
is a tree a graph is a tree and see what
happens
okay so
okay firstly this equation is very nice
because
it's
it's expressing what we want to compute
on the original graph
as in terms of probabilities that you
want to compute in g minus u so there's
some sort of recursion going on but the
problem with this recursion is that
the left hand side is a degree one
marginal it's about one what happens in
condition one vertex and you're ending
up trying to compute that in terms of
um
the
marginal of the entire neighborhood i
need to fix all these variables so let's
see if there's a way around it well
there is a way around it if your graph
is a tree
well if your graph is a tree
then when you fix and when you look at
this variable
u and then you have sub trees here
once i delete this vertex
i have
trees that are disconnected
what that means is the neighborhood
all the vertices in the neighborhood
become independent once you delete that
vertex
okay
and so that's a huge simplification now
because the joint distribution of the
entire neighborhood
is a product distribution
now we can figure out the joint
distribution of the entire neighborhood
in terms of
just the individual marginals of each of
the nodes
here in the neighbor
okay
so this big this quantity
in a tree becomes a product
over all the neighbors
that particular neighbor
is assigned the value
right so in a tree they have a huge
simplification
and so now if you once on a tree you
really have a nice recursion
because the left hand side
is a degree one marginal
degree one marginalizes a margin for
single vertex
and the right hand side now is also a
degree one margin
okay
so we so you can hope to come use
this relation on a tree and as you can
remove vertices and
can
it's like dynamic programming
and in fact
all you need is
some definition here so let's define
this mij
this m i to j
is the
marginal distribution of
vertex i
if j were absent
so
it's basically
if i delete this once i delete this
vertex u
i want to know what is the marginal
distribution of
each of these word roots of the sub
trees
each of these vertices v
okay and so what you really want to know
is the marginal distribution of this a
vertex v in the situation where the
vertex u did not exist
okay
meaning of the deleted vertex
okay and if you have defined this
mij
then you can
you can actually write down
the
marginal of u in terms of the margin of
the neighborhood of you right you can
write a relation which looks like
the marginal of vertex u
is some function psi
of the marginals of all the
incoming values
v to u
you do have this notion that you just
have the proportionality rather than
equality
is that an issue
[Music]
well no not really because of because um
so in some sense the proportionality
what is proportionality mean here well
this side the left hand side is a
function of sigma u right it's some
function h of sigma u
okay and what we know is that we can
calculate h of plus one and h of minus
one
okay you know it sums up to one so you
you normalize it yes okay right it's a
good question yeah so you can just
normalize it you compute h of plus one h
of minus one then you normalize it then
you get uh this
okay so
uh so that's it so basically in a tree
you we have this nice
recursion and you have a dynamic
programming type algorithm
and uh it's also
um
has a knight has this nice form where
for every vertex
in some sense
um
you have on the edges
you have
these marginals which are which every
other neighbor sends it
okay so m v to u
m
v prime to u
so you have marginals coming in at every
vertex
and
what does this vertex do it applies this
function on it and it that becomes its
marginal so in a tree you know if you
think of a tree as having a root and
so on
you know the outgoing message
from
this vertex
this vertex u to one to its pair and w
is a function of
the incoming messages
so you say m u to w is actually this
function of this incoming messages
okay
[Music]
yeah so so that's uh on a tree
everything works fine so what what is
the algorithm on a tree well you know
let's say you
i mean you don't have to do it but you
could do it this way you root it and
then you start computing the marginal's
bottom up and you get the margins
okay so that you can do that
okay so what is the cavity method
well the cavity method is now
we have this
definition of messages and we have
a way to calculate things on a tree
and
in many situations
the locally
things
do have this cavity property or the
cavity hypothesis that they behave like
the tree meaning
the values of the neighbors of you are
independent once you condition on you
right so
this is a
hypothesis
right so we are making this
assumption and we'll proceed after we
make this assumption so it's an
assumption that we have to make making
okay
okay so why is such a thing true
well the reason you would hope such a
thing is true like say in all our
problems is that if i look at a graph
okay look at the vertex u
okay look at all its neighbors
as we saw in the beginning of the last
lecture
the neighborhood of every vertex looks
like a tree
meaning all the cycles are long
right all the cycles are long so in
particular if i look at two vertices v
and w here
okay
if you want to go from v to w you have
to take probably a long path probably
like a log n length path
to go to v from v to w
because
typically cycle sizes are like order log
n in these graphs
so
so in some sense
if you
like if you took away the vertex you
you think that the word the the
neighbors are far away from each other
so they become independent
but you know there are many i mean
like that's probably a reason you know
reasoning say okay maybe this is true
but let's just proceed right for now
assuming this is true
okay so assuming this is true
what what can we do now well we can
try to use the same update rule
in a general graph
so in a general graph
you have all the vertices here on every
edge
you have
on every edge uv
you have two directions
you have two two variables associated
with it one is the message from u to v
and the other is a message from v to u
all of these messages are distributions
over 0 1
distributions over the assignments or
plus 1 minus 1.
okay the messages are all product
distributions or assignments and they're
just
stating the fact that
m u to v is the marginal distribution of
u in the absence of v
and so on and you're pretending that the
whole thing is a tree
if it was a tree
then you'd have the
at every point
over here at every node
you have the following thing you have
let's say these are the edges here
at every node
every edge m u to v for instance the
message out of u towards v
is some function psi
bp
of
the incoming messages on the remaining
edges
m
w to u
w in the neighborhood of u
but not equal to v
okay in a tree you know intuitively we
started with this idea that there's a
root and this is like a special
direction and
the message to the root is a function of
the message you get from the children
but in a general graph there is no
direction associated so you pretend
the message on every edge leaving on any
edge is a function of the messages
incoming on the other edges
okay
you know it depends on them well it's
not the same function it depends on the
degree
well sorry
uh
yeah i guess
yeah
generally depend on the weights of
things like that
right
yeah like in let's say in stochastic
block model um it depends on the just on
the db
um right because degree of view
being of you but it's the same function
uh it's the plastic block model
uh for every
on every edge of the same beam
every vertex at the same time
um basically as degree changes the
number of things you multiply
uh
changes
but in general yeah um if you had if you
did this with the let's see if you want
to do this with
something like a csp that can not only
equal set
then the clean way to do it is to not
you should have two sets of nodes in
your graph the variables and the
constraints with the variable constraint
graph and do the entire all of the
cavity calculations over there
so when you remove a variable the
constraint will have an option and we
will constrain the variables or not
so this is what
so this is a property
that we hypothesize to be true
for
the distribution that we care about
that you know the
locally at every node
there is there are these numbers mu
that characterize the distribution and
these numbers satisfy some relation
language so it's like a six point
relation
okay so you have some thing and you want
to find a fixed point of this relation
so
okay let's take the leap of faith and
try to do the natural thing you start at
one point
and you keep applying the same update
rule again and again and hope that it
converges to the fixed point
okay
so that is a bpr within here so what you
do you have messages on every edge in
both directions
on a graph
and
you initialize these messages to some
value will come to that
later
and then after you initialize it to some
value
you just keep running the update
what's this
awesome
questions on this um
except that
if we do this we are updating all the
messages at the same time
um so it will but if you but you can
prove that it works in trees it's not
that hard
okay so this is the bp algorithm
okay so and uh you know we don't know
how many steps you want to run and so on
okay so let's
think about this algorithm a little bit
what are the cons and the pros well
let's start with the cons
the con that i find very surprising
a little bit uh
difficult for them
for me typically is that nothing about
bp is obviously correct
there's no obvious there are very few
obvious facts that you can prove to be
true
about bp
um so
in particular
firstly okay bp is running this fixed
point iteration to arrive at a fixed
point
it's difficult to prove that you
actually converge to a fixed point
okay so let's say let's ignore that
issue let's say i ran an exponential
time algorithm
to find the fixed point
okay
it's we don't know if there's one fixed
point or n any number of fixed points
and even if you found a fixed point even
if there's a unique fixed point your
relation and you found it
we still don't know
that
that fixed point corresponds to the
distribution that you care about
because for interconnection
under the cavity hypothesis
well
even that you can't really prove
that it's not like i can write down a
one-line cavity assumption under which
the bp fixed point is the true true
distribution
the cavity hypothesis is that
the two marginals are a fixed point of
the vp
uh yeah you could say that yeah you
could see that but but you know better
even though there it's a bit subtle
because if we take the cavity assumption
to be formulated to like you know if you
say it has to be actually true then
they're in trouble because their things
are never going to be actually pulling
it's not equality right yeah things will
never be fully independent then they'll
be approximately independent and you
have to
make an approximate assumption
so nothing about it is obviously true so
like usually in narratives you know
things that are obviously correct and
then
you hope that something works but here
nothing is obviously true
as i said it's difficult to analyze
because uh because i didn't write down
the
uh
update rule
and probably i have achieved that at
some point
i'll write down the update for sbm but
it's quite the non-linear update rule
and
another thing is of course it's
difficult to talk about robustness of dp
because
you know it's a discrete dynamical
system it's hard to know where it goes
right if you mess up some um things so
it's quite a difficult thing to do
but what are the pros firstly it's very
efficient right you know it's a near
linear time when some sense right and uh
yeah yeah
yeah it works well in experiments right
i mean this is uh not just experiments i
mean it's also used heavily like right
so it's like a very useful algorithm
right unlike sos yes for now
and then uh
like from even from a theoretical
standpoint the reason it's very
interesting is that
i mean all the things that we said
are not obviously true
are so many times true for deeper
reasons and the whole fund is improving
that they're true right and
in particular
for many cases it is true these facts
are obvious are true
or and
in a sense bp does characterize the
optimal mean square error in many
situations
so let me show why that sort of is the
case
right so um so bp fixed points
uh are
local minima of uh function called the
beta free interface that they free
energy with the free energy so when bp
arrives at a fixed point or if you look
at any bp fixed point it it's a local
minimum of a better free energy but
better f energy is not a convex function
and it's and this is not a gradient like
this is not gradient descent on on that
are they local minima or just i think
they're just first order critical points
right
like they don't know oh yes yes also yes
you said this first of all
yeah they're not really locally normal
okay so why is okay from even from
theoretical standpoint that we did all
this why is it very interesting well um
why is vp interesting because you know
let's say you're interested in what is
the optimal
recovery rate you can get for let's say
stochastic block model
okay so let's fix our vertex u
and how do you write down output
required let's fix the vertex u
fix its label to plus one
now sample the entire stochastic block
model the rest of the graph
okay
okay and then
you ask
under the posterior distribution
p of x comma g x given z
what is the probability that x u is 1
okay
so what does this tell us well if i
started with the label u being 1
and then you know the rest of the
vertices took some value plus one minus
one and then you sample the graph and
the condition on the graph you get back
a sample from your for a planting what
is the chance that you get back plus one
right and that really is the in some
sense the optimal recovery rate you can
hope
here you can't hope to get any recovery
rate better than that
okay
right okay so that's good
so so this is uh like if you want to
understand this number like this is a
number in 0 and 1
right and it tells you in some sense how
well you can recover the
original
planted
partition if you
okay and and
above the casting stick and threshold we
expect this to be
um or in fact above the statistical
threshold we expect this to be some
non-trivial number and below it should
be zero tending to zero
okay so how does
like suppose you think about
characterizing this number finding
proving the value of this number is
something
so
let's say you took this leap and you say
okay let
okay for whenever you
do this experiment
okay
you will
you will get some
uh probability for xu equal to plus one
okay some product of x equal plus one
let d be the distribution of values of
this
okay so d is a distribution of 0 1
it's a distribution over 0 1 which
which is whenever you do this experiment
what is the probability that
x u equal to plus 1 in the
so each time it is actually you get a
probability and some distribution d
okay
and so now let's pretend
that this distribution is actually a
real thing it doesn't depend on n it
doesn't depend on this it actually
exists okay let's pretend that d exists
it's not clear that d exists right
meaning
uh maybe
it's a mixture of two distributions and
things like that so you know let's say d
exists and for every n it is the same
distribution and some distribution
exists
okay and then uh
let's also pretend the following is true
that
if you look at any particular graph from
in sbm
okay look at different vertices
the vertices have and look at the
distribution of these marginal values
that is also d
right one is averaging over graphs it's
some d
and the other is in a given graph
so let's pretend that it's d there's a
distribution d
okay
okay so then what what happens now
well
here's a relation that d satisfies
okay so
uh
so in g minus
how
we've we talked about how to sample the
neighborhood of a vertex u how do we
sample the vertex neighbor of vertex u
we take u
and
we sample the poisson number of minus
neighbors and we sample a poisson number
of plus neighbors
okay
you take samples from poisson number of
minus inversion plus minus trust
neighbors and you ask all the neighbors
what their
marginal values are their marginal
values are by assumption
examples from d
they're all samples from b
well d plus and d minus but d n minus d
but
but they're all samples given by this
distribution d
right
okay
so
in some sense
like and the output of the of your
vertex is also a sample from b
right
just because of your assumption that
the
assumption that they are independent
yeah yeah under the cavity assumption
yeah assume that the cavity assumption
and uh
so so
d becomes a fixed point of the following
relation
right
b is a fixed point of the following
distributional
relation
what is it you sample
two
numbers r and s
which is the number of vertices plus
what is a number of minus neighbors
okay
and you take d sub r samples from d and
one minus ah
sorry s samples from one minus d okay
you take samples
alpha these are the samples and then you
plug them into this bp update rule
which takes in numbers and gives out a
number so it spits out a number gamma
okay
so you have this uh
constant sized
i mean
effectively constant sized
uh
operation right because uh
r and s are constants d in and d out are
constants so it's really there's no n in
this
it's a the key point is n is out of the
picture
we have a fixed point relation on
a constant size fixed point relation on
distributions over zero one
so if b was this distribution of zero
one
we
tend to think that
it satisfies this
fixed point relation meaning you do this
operation the number your output is also
from b
that gamma is also from b
okay and that's the
beauty of this so now you know we had no
handle on d like
you know we had to do this n you know
this thing on n vertex graphs and you
know it was super hard but now suddenly
we have a surprisingly strong handle on
d
the distribution of these marginal
values
right it's surprisingly all of a sudden
it's the solution to a fixed point
relation of constant size if you write
it out with some algebraic you know if
you write it out with some constant size
algebraic
set of equations it's a set of equations
and d is a solution to that
in a sense
okay but it's a distributional fixed
point here um
it's a fixed point relation for d yeah
okay is it clear any questions on this
so so so
so that's the reason why bp is
interesting so in the sense that when
you try to characterize these things
like what is the optimal recovery rate
or what is the you know
mutual information the mean mean squared
error and so on your naturally the
cavity hypothesis
starts giving you answers
and of course there's a whole
difficulties in proving that the
assumptions you made on the way are true
that's the technical difficulty but at
least this tells you where to go
and this
i mean
i think
again and again this sort of thing
has been formalized rigorously in many
many settings there's a whole line of
work by
will perkins and kojo glenn
and also the
abbey montenarie and lots of works on
these things in
lots of settings
you prove that the bp fixed point
gives you the right answer so usually
here
it will actually be the case that would
be a unique
fixed point and that will give you the
right distribution or
no i think it's very difficult to
prove things i mean it needed a lot of
work to prove things about the fixed
point the structure
only the
dissociative case has been solved and
the associative case is still not solved
or the other way around
um like you need to make additional like
now the question like at least one of
the technical questions is to as words
were saying to understand the uh
solution space of fixed points of this
distribution relation for example
statistical physicists would look at
that and then we would say okay some of
these solutions are non-physical and
then the one that's physical will kind
of yeah
yeah usually i think it's the um
basically
free energy and the one that maximizes
that sort of
um
the entropy
yeah
[Music]
right
sometimes the gravity equation is
validated and and then
uh works but there is a regime's word
with you
yeah the probability doesn't work or
break once the replication implementing
happens
like these cavity assumptions won't be
true
and then but you know we have to do
survey propagation or something but this
i just want to give a flavor of
why these things are very
um
why this thing is very useful some of
the cavity assumption it lets you
um start attacking these questions
yeah
[Music]
okay so
all right so now let's go back to the
algorithm so now okay let's look at bp
again so the one thing we left out was
what is the initialization how do i
initialize these uh
messages okay there's an usually in in
all of the bayesian csps that i
described there is a notion of a naive
initialization which for stochastic
block model corresponds to saying
um
every
marginal is with half probability plus
one
and half protein minus one
okay it's the
natural initialization
okay let's see what happens when you do
this
well three things can happen
firstly
you
start with this naive initialization and
you get stuck there or you don't get
stuck there meaning
bp in one nitration does something it
goes somewhere else
okay this
is
means that your original point is not a
fixed point it's a good case like you
don't get stuck in your first step so
that's good so and in fact you can prove
that
uh you can get non-trivial recovery here
um exercise i must have said
i i shouldn't say bp is not really
because i don't know how to
i don't know how to prove it but but
it's easy to get not to recover in these
cases
because it's some degree balance that's
not that's failing it's for example if
you sample a planted three sat in the
naive distribution
uh by just by looking at the variable
whether it's negated or not you can
figure out whether
the variable should be zero or one
right and so so so this is an easy case
okay
okay but now let's say you are this
naive initialization is a fixed point
meaning
you
uh
the bp doesn't move from there you start
with that you stay there okay in fact
for stochastic block model this is a
fixed point
right because if all the
neighbors
say that they're uniformly randomly plus
or minus 1
by symmetry
the vertex will also be uniformly random
b plus or minus 1 just by symmetry so
there's this issue that if m is a fixed
point but uh
then you're sort of stuck
but even if in this case there are two
things that can happen
one is your fixed point is somehow
unstable okay this how all halves was
bad let's say i perturb it a little bit
does it do i move away if all half or is
this knife fixed point is unstable then
the prediction is that
there is an efficient recovery is
possible
and if the fixed point is stable
then
it you cannot have
the prediction is that no efficient
algorithm can get non-trivial recovery
for for this particular uh
initialization in fact it's a
for
you can think of the initialization as
you had a prior
right you just substitute the prior as
your initialization
okay and
right yeah
no i mean the right right no that's the
that's the claim yeah that is the claim
right right now i mean prediction is
really a prediction right it's a yeah i
mean the that's the nice thing so it's
really very simple to describe so
it is saying that if you take this naive
initialization substitute it and if the
fixed point is unstable then you have an
algorithm you should have an algorithm
if it's stable you shouldn't have an
album
okay so
so i've been saying
stable but really what i meant was
stable on an infinite tree
unstable on infinite tree okay so let's
see let me see what that is
so how much time
okay
okay
okay
yeah okay so let's see how much i can
calculate and things but okay so what is
stability on infinite tree well okay as
we said our neighborhoods look like
trees
right this is infinite tree and let's
say you go up to some
distance l okay and
what we know is that we are at a fixed
point right
so if every node says
i am uniformly randomly half
okay then its parents also say half and
everybody says half so it's like a fixed
point okay everything is
it's a fixed point and so then uh
what does stability mean
if i take the
if i take the nodes at
the children at depth l
and i perturb their
values by epsilon
plus or minus epsilon
i perturb the name values of the leaves
by plus or minus epsilon
and then i ask
does the root change
the value of the root change
in particular
let's say epsilon is some fixed number
so for every
epsilon
for sufficiently
large depth
l
okay you want that the marginal output
of the root
has some variance it starts
at its
variance surface is strictly greater
than zero then we would say this is
unstable
[Music]
yeah let's say maybe stable means that
for every epsilon
there is a delta such that if l is
sufficiently large then the variance is
less than delta
yeah
yes
yeah
now that's the right order of
quantifiers so you say for every epsilon
if i perturb by epsilon
[Music]
if i go sufficiently large depth
i should be able to make the output
perturbation smaller than delta for any
delta that's stable
but if i see the perturbation in the
root that's unstable
variance because i defined it so that
the
it's a random perturbation at the leaves
i made a random perturbation release
right um
yeah so the perturbation was random at
the leaves you're asking what happens at
the root
okay so that's what stability of an
infinite uh
tree is so it's so again um
the key point here is uh there is
by saying something about an infinite
tree there is no n here
so
right that's sort of the key point here
in that uh this is a prediction which
like you make
this a property of the model as opposed
to any given n
because of its infinite property of the
tree and so and the claim is that when
the model satisfies stable when a model
has stable fixed points the knife
expands stable then it's a no efficient
algorithm when the knife explains
unstable there there is an efficient
algorithm
okay
yeah a question
between those three faces and the
solution space geometry
[Music]
um
um
yeah i i don't know maybe single
announcement i don't know it's better
yeah i i don't know if there's a
connection
known between uh stability of fixed
points and solution space geometry yeah
all right what sort of perturbations are
allowed could i have collaborate
colluding
these are random plus minus
perturbations independent independent
random plus minus definitions
so
actually i was hoping to do this
calculation and prove that this is
actually
shows that the value of the custom
string threshold d epsilon squared is
greater than one the problem is easy and
the epsilon squared less than one less
than is hard you can derive the custom
threshold from here but i guess i do and
run out of time uh if i try to write it
but because i want to cover other things
but but the point the key point is that
this is a property of the model and it's
also quite easy to check whether
something is stable
on the infinite tree
i mean it's
it needs a little bit of work but you
can basically construct
like a finite size matrix whose
spectral properties tell you whether
whether it's stable or not
so we can write a computer program to
check if it's stable or not according to
this definition
okay
okay so that's stability in the tree and
this is a very bold conjecture right now
okay and what
the positive side of the prediction here
is as efficient
uh it's possible with bp or uh not with
bt um well this should like the
the positive progression that should be
possible but uh
like in community detection all of the
work by uh borderline
detection and in recent work with uh
mohanty and
liu
we show that this is positive side is
true
for
all bayesian csps like all of the models
it's a generalization of this blm
non-backtracking work uh what happened
to community models but it's just the
the positive side is true so in all the
blue regions there is an efficient
algorithm to get non-trivial recovery so
that's prediction has been confirmed
it's confirmed it is confirmed
or not it's a spectral algorithm
it is known not to
work of bp yeah we
yeah i don't know what the belief is
whether bp should work or everywhere but
uh yeah there's probably one algorithm
that has long-range correlations
right
right right yeah yeah actually so i mean
so i'll actually come to this issue of
algorithms tomorrow i want to state to
talk about this local and global
algorithms but the point is somehow that
bp is easier to analyze
if you are
somewhat
correlated with the true solution so
some constant amount of correlation with
the true solution you start at a random
point we don't know how to analyze bp
because it's a non-linear update rule
and a fairly non-linear update basically
we can analyze bp for constant number of
rounds
and even that is very difficult it's
very difficult to analyze bp for login
rounds
and to come to solve these problems you
need to have something like a power
iteration which does log in round like a
like a login round thing yeah
and i don't know what the belief is
whether bp should work in general
because
yeah because i mean
yeah because
sometimes i don't think statistical
physics intuitions tell us anything
about
that bp should work here because bp
um coming up to the point where we did
cavity method it was all statistical
physics and the point at which said okay
we want to find a fixed point legislate
we went away from physics i think we are
in our own now so
um outside of stochastic block model
believe propagation probably fails uh
for for random constellation reflection
problem it it probably fails the
regardless of the number of iterations
so i i guess it's open for the within
the domain of stochastic block models
yeah but not so much was the catalog
model so the conjunction is
within the
force models
it's not that they
precisely state this conjecture for a
given problem in any of the papers it's
sort of this intuition which taking out
in the text where about when applied to
different problems and each of the cases
the claim is that well it is not a fixed
point it's unstable when you send them
insulin stabilization
and then yeah yes i should yeah
i should maybe not uh maybe this is like
a bit of my interpretation of the papers
in the sense yeah
but so the intuition why the navy's
initialization
makes sense to look at is that basically
if it's not a fixed point you would
expect at least
that
you can at least do some non-trial
recovery in the sense that you get
something that's correlated with the
solution and you don't get exactly the
solution but you get something that's
correlated with it yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i mean the naive
initialization invasion csp is very
natural it's just the priority started
it's like the prior on the variables so
um yeah
okay so that's good all right so
okay so
so in fact this is how we drew all the
pictures that i showed earlier you do
this calculation on the infinite tree it
is a you can write a program to do that
and you say when it's stable and it's
unstable you can draw those pictures
it's a
good
exercise
right okay so now let's let's see how we
can take this bp intuition to get an
actual algorithm provable algorithm
and the idea is also very
much
there already so what is the idea well
you know
let's just analyze stability of
bp
of the bp update rule in a general graph
okay so what is it so you have a fixed
point here so you have a fixed point
okay
these are let's say the knife fixed
point is
this is the name fixed point
and then you want to know what whether
the fixed point is stable
well the fixed point is stable stable
you know
if you just do taylor series expansion
or take a linear approximation
you can write down the difference
when you put up the input by a little
bit by epsilon
the output perturbation is is given by
the jacobian
of the bp update rule so note that psi
is a map
from r to the
uh two times e
to r it's a it's a
it's a multivariate function
it takes two times e variables
and gives out two times the variables
right it's a map and you can write down
its jacobian which is the matrix of
partial derivatives you can write down
the matrix of partial derivatives and
you know the standard calculus thing the
fixed point is stable
in a sense if and only if the spectral
norm
of this uh
matrix is less than one
okay so i mean one key point is that now
i'm talking about stability in a general
graph and so but i'm just but we're
trying to use the same intuition and say
okay let's just look at the fixed point
since you've talked about random epsilon
should it be some kind of convenience
norm or should it be uh
uh yeah okay so um
so it is the spectral norm uh and uh
uh
okay so the reason we looked at random
perturbation in the tree
and the best worst case perturbation in
a general graph is that
if you look at
the the spectral norm of jf's psi
for a general graph for a general graph
j of size spectral norm is controlled by
the random perturbation quantity in a
tree
essentially if you want to say the idea
is that in terms every neighborhood
has every vertex has its own tree
right and so whatever assignment you put
whatever perturbation you put
for most of the vertices the
perturbation looks random from their
point of view
right but basically uh i mean there's no
uh
i mean that's the intuition which i'm
giving but but this is a formal theorem
you can prove that
if okay let's look at this matrix this
matrix is now
uh it's an uh it's a matrix of partial
derivatives
okay just to
it's an important matrix to know so let
me just say how big it is it's two times
edges for every edge there are two rows
and two columns for it for every edge
okay and
the non-zero entries of this matrix are
only on
entries of the form i j to j k
so if i have i j
h i j
and then a j k
in the column i j
i to j and the call row j k but rho
there's a non-zero entry
which is given by the partial derivative
of the bp update rule
for this vertex
okay um i actually plan to write this
down but i guess we're running out of
time but you can essentially
you know
write down the entries of the matrix one
by one because uh
you know it's really the list of partial
derivatives of a polynomial relation or
non-linear update rule that you wrote
down okay evaluated at a point
so
so and so that's
the matrix
and the claim is if that matrix has
spectrum less than one and the fixed
point is stable if it's more than one
the fixed point is unstable okay
and
this
matrix this
the spectral norm of this
matrix is the distinguisher between
the
planted and random
that we can use to get an algorithm so
in particular in stochastic block model
which is our original problem
these partial derivatives are all some
fixed constants
some is a particular fixed constant e to
the minus beta
okay it's a it's a fixed constant
actually it's not this is
okay so
so what that means is that this matrix
of partial derivatives
is
you have a it's e to the minus beta
times
a one
on the entry
i to j j to k
you put a one whenever
for every for every edge
uh i j
and j k
put a one
that's the matrix and that's a
non-backtracking work matrix okay
and
the spectral norm of this
non-backtracking work matrix
um
controls the um
[Music]
it's just a spectrum of this non-binary
work matrix it turns out is a
distinguisher between planted and random
and that's the part which requires a
proof what do we need to prove we need
to prove that when this
condition on infinite tree
the stability condition on the infinity
holes
then the spectral norm
of this random matrix
is bounded
and when when it is unstable it's you
haven't you have a large eigenvalue
okay so
if you translate the stability condition
on a tree to the spectral norm of random
matrices that you draw from it
for example for uh um stochastic block
model it's just like you take an
adoration graph and construct this
non-backtracking work matrix you need to
prove that the eigenvalue the largest
eigenvalue
after you take out the trivial
eigenvalue is at most square root d
you know in a reductioning staff and
that's what
blm did
um and uh we do it for a more general
model of not only equal csps i said not
just bayesian csps
for just for bayesian csbs
it's true that the random matrices that
you get
have spectral norms
that can work as distinguishers between
plantar and random
yeah sorry yeah it is a bit messed up
any questions on this
that's because of the following simple
reason that in general
in general
right if i look at the partial
derivative of the i to j
in terms of k to l
this is 0
unless
l is equal to i
because
it for every vertex the output message
is just a function of these input
messages
right so this is the output message i to
j is just a function of edges that enter
here
it's independent like when you come
differentiate partially derivative it
will be zero if you try to take a
positive with respect to some other head
somewhere that's why you get this
non-backtracking structure naturally
um
any other questions um
so
yeah
okay so that i talked about the
detection
you know the
recovery is a little bit more subtle
than what you expect because eigenvec
remember that this is a non this matrix
is not a symmetric matrix so its
eigenvalues are actually complex
so it's not
it doesn't naturally correspond to an
optimization problem
in the sense that you can't take the
eigenvector of this matrix and
think of it as
the
solution to some optimization problem as
in it doesn't correspond to max cut or
min cut in the usual way spectral
eigenvalue vectors of laplacians do
so it
so recovery is more subtle than
[Music]
what you usually expect from spectral
algorithm just take the eigenvector and
do something with it
okay i think i'll stop here tomorrow
i'll talk about sum of squares
[Applause]
yeah
more questions
all right